hey everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2019 it's day 2 I'm Lucy
James joined by Mike Mahadi and here to
talk about the dark pictures man of
Madden we have game director Tom Heaton
and one of the stars shawn ashmore guys
welcome thank you
hi so how is it III been for you yeah
it's been awesome incredible you know
it's always a massive events it's full
of people it's full of buzz so I mean I
we haven't got add my shots and check
out the show floor to be honest we've
been really busy but it's just been
awesome yeah it's my first time here so
I've thoroughly enjoyed it and I have to
say this is actually one of my favorite
stages the artwork is fantastic school
drew ray he's not here but good work so
what are you bringing to this show so I
played banner for Dan back at Gamescom
last year a brief demo what are you
bringing this year's e3 okay so we
haven't we have a another demo that
we're showing Manama Dan is it's the
first of the dark pictures anthology
it's a series of standalone games horror
games and from supermassive games so
we're excited to show it there's a the
demo was showing features Shawn playing
Conrad it's a very exciting little
section of the game it's a very
branching narrative you know all our
games of these huge branching narratives
and this little section it really shows
that offers lots of outcomes that come
out of what the player chooses to do in
this people living or dying or whole
scenes that'll play out or not the
anthology format works well with horror
right you can see it in like the VHS
short it's like a collection of short
stories that like did you pull
inspiration from that when you're
approaching this like why go with the
anthology format rather than what just
what you did with it also so one of the
reasons was must be finished upon till
dawn we kind of sat down and try to work
out what we want to do next and we're
big horror fans in the studio horror
movies horror games you know we love all
that and we'll sit down and talk about
them and analyze some of things so one
of the things about horror is they it's
not
one thing it splits into loads and loads
of subgenus and we were listing out all
the subgenus of horror and which we were
interested in doing there was something
like 39 or 40 different subgenres and
from that we kind of got the idea of not
just working on one thing but working on
our anthology that would allow us to
explore those subgenus you know one by
one and take them learn them understand
them and kind of get the tropes from
those use the tropes in the game and
subvert them so how did you come to
decide on mana for Danford the first
outing we wanted something that was a
striking that was really exciting we had
this idea of a kind of ghost ship
so people isolated at sea that's always
cool with horror to get people isolated
in an environment they're not familiar
with at all so that worked well for us
there were obviously film inspirations
like go ship and triangle we watched
those movies and kind of again under
understood how they worked yeah it was
it was it's that whole thing of getting
a bunch of characters and putting them
in a situation that's very uncomfortable
for them and very scary for them we've
always had this thing all our characters
can live and all of them can die so as
you're playing the game and making
choices and things you never know what
the repercussions of what you're doing
oh how did you know like how easy it is
to die off in a super massive game yeah
well I played until dawn you know we
were talking earlier about about quantum
break and when I was doing that I was
paying attention to super massive and
until dawn because they were making
games with sort of recognizable actors
that were performance driven and
narrative driven which I was obviously
very interested in as an actor so coming
into manmad and I was very aware of how
how easy potentially it is to dive how
how gruesome and graphic it could be
sometimes but yeah for me it was
exciting because you know one of the
major things I think for actors coming
into games right now
the
exciting is that the technology is at a
place where the performance you do on
the day can be captured and then
delivered to the player you know which
is exciting the nuance is the detail
that you want to try to bring to it so
that's an exciting thing and also I love
bold storytelling in games like that's
something that I wanted you as a player
as an audience member so yeah jump onto
a supermassive game especially at the
beginning of this you know exciting
anthology was cool for me and I just had
a lot of fun too horror stories allow
you to sort of take a performance take a
story and really push it you know to the
extreme which again as an actor is
always really fun so there was a some
big exciting sequences that are really
truly scary and the other thing that's
crazy there's so much branching content
on this and I'm i sometimes catch little
details like I'm watching some of the
the cutscenes here I'm like oh I forgot
about that detail like even though I've
done it I've sort of forgotten about all
the details so I think even for me as a
player when I go back and play it even
though I was experiencing the whole
thing making it there's details I kind
of forget about some of them so it's
kind of cool how did you end up working
on the game did supermassive reach out
to you or did you reach out to them yeah
it was like most you know opportunities
in my career I just got a phone call
from my agent saying you know I actually
don't when the first call came in I
don't know that it was really specific
it was kind of like a little cagey like
hey there's this opportunity to be a
part of this game and and then maybe a
few days later I got sent sort of
some-some concept art and the idea and
that's when I realized oh it's
supermassive and it's like their new
title so yeah and then again I
immediately was interested in working
with the studio I was actually kind of
all-in after the concept before I even
really looked at the character and then
I was like okay cool and you know Conrad
the character I play is this kind of
brash over-the-top American tourist
he's like a self-proclaimed ladies man
so he's he's not like the subtlest
character I've ever played but it was
kind of fun and again he pushes the
envelope and and sort of his attitude
and his personality helped instigate
some of the things that start to go
wrong in the game so
kind of fun to be a part of that just in
the storytelling aspects - Tom how was
it why was it you approached Shawn
specifically for this yet huh
it's weird working the game studio which
is quite a you know it's quite a good
deaky nerdy environment and we sit there
for a long time to give these stories
thinking of the characters you know so
important to us to get really strong
distinctive characters the people can
relate to
straight away you know they need to pick
out the character and though they're
playing the mini to relate to them
really clearly also that the characters
have depth but and they grow over the
course of the game so one of the things
that's really important to us is to get
really good talent and to help us bring
those characters to life and someone
like Paul there's someone like Sean Paul
is someone like Sean comes along and
really brings the character comrade to
life
it's awesome for us it's really exciting
first as you say the data capture now it
is really acting we really do get every
nuance once we get that back to the
studio
and we start putting the scenes together
it's just amazing you know it's
everything worked on it suddenly brought
to life it's incredible is it weird
seeing yourself I mean you must've had
this experience with quantum break
seeing yourself in a game but how is
that I mean as the technology is getting
better and everything is it still weird
like an uncanny valley where you know it
is you but it's also not you it's
getting closer and closer like I just
caught a close-up and I was like that
looks almost photo real like the D and I
always think this I'm like well you know
I start to see like wrinkles and stuff
I'm like couldn't you guys just smooth
that out a little bit but I mean the
point is is like all all those details
all those nuances all those tiny little
twitch muscles that you couldn't capture
before that is what to me really takes
the performance and the story to the
next level and hopefully what pulls
players in and engages them where it
feels like you know real so yeah that's
always my joke whenever I see like that
get sent like the the details like sign
offs like okay this what the image is
gonna look like and I'm like you
couldn't smooth me out a little bit but
no it's it's really cool and
it is actually a very different
experience than seeing yourself even on
film or television because you're so
much more removed you know you're sort
of like more of a passive audience so I
could sit and watch this narrative story
if I'm in a movie or a television show
but to actually take the control and be
in control of life-or-death situations
which games tend to to create for four
players it's kind of weird so yeah I
definitely will probably wince a few
times when I when I first play through
this and you know potentially get myself
killed it's gonna be great Tom you're
saying obviously there's that trademark
supermassive branching storylines based
on decisions as an anthology and if are
you like are those decisions that we're
gonna carry into any of the other
chapters like I know anthologies by
definition usually don't have anything
to do with each other but super massive
I feel like if anybody could make them
work together you guys that's not the
plan so that they are standalone story
so every time you think of a game in the
Derby's anthology it's a standalone
stories and new narrative it's new
characters it's a new cast and it's cool
at me so if any game you play you don't
have to have played any of the other
games you can just jump jump straight in
what we have done is put a couple of
connecting threads between the games so
one of those is the the character of the
curator you might have seen him in some
of the trailers and that's this guy it's
an old guy who he lives in this kind of
library we call the repository he
welcomes you to the game and he kind of
tells you stuff about it and as you're
playing he'll put he back in as a player
he'll kind of talk to you directly as a
player
and ask you how you think you're doing
and do you want any hints and things and
he's a little bit sinister and you don't
know whether to trust him so he's in all
the doll pictures games and he kind of
has a story arc obviously so you'll see
him and the other thing is we have these
are these real connecting links between
the games they're subtler little Easter
eggs there for people to look out for
maybe they'll give hints about games to
come or they'll refer back to to earlier
games in the series once Easter eggs so
read it or go mad yeah that's the idea
that's the idea that we get people
looking that kind of superfans and
they'll try and piece everything
together
what learnings did you
from working on until dawn especially
when it comes to the narrative which was
like incredibly ambitious and paid off
because you had all of these characters
you know even though some of them were
kind of jerks you did care about them by
their that if one of them died you did
genuinely feel bad what did you take
from that game that you bring in to
death I mean so much stuff so is a hue
as a studio is a huge learning
experience for us we built up so much
experience in the team and a lot of the
team that worked on on till dawn and
working on the dark picture series you
know we learnt about cinematic
presentation and great lighting and then
the importance of audio and stuff like
that in terms of narrative yeah it was
all about the very strong narrative
there was very well drawn characters one
of the big things for us was until dawn
launched was the number of people
streaming it we kind of we didn't
anticipate that we'd been deep in
development and suddenly this whole
streaming world was there and people
were playing the game and other people
watching it and commenting on it and
that was so cool for us that was it was
not something we anticipated at all and
it was something we were really
enthusiastic about really helps us help
people understand what the game was and
get people enthusiastic about the game
so that was really cool and the other
thing was that people played it in a
group we we kind of didn't anticipate
that but it was a big thing of people
getting four or five people in a room
getting some beers in or whatever I'm
playing the game together everyone
picking a character try to keep that
character alive I mean that was really
that was great to see to see that and we
really tried to you know people we hope
people do that with them with mantan and
we kind of put things to help enable
that and made that really fun experience
yeah I don't know what kind of choices
were made but Conrad looks in rough
shape yeah it happens I've done much
voiceover our Vasari voice acting
outside of games know and to be honest
like I don't even really truly consider
the big thing at least Kwanza break in
Menna Madden like voice acting because
we do a full motion capture so it's like
the whole performance I did do some
voice work for a x-men game I think it
was when x-men The Last Stand was out
they
it was the bridging one yeah x-men two
and x-men three yes it's the one that
Nightcrawler got written out of that's
right yeah
yeah so I did some voice work for that
game and I've done a few sort of
cartoons but not a lot to be honest I'd
love to do it I think it's I think it's
really fun I like again the difference
between being on set with a camera and
lighting and all that where it's like
very restrictive like you rehearse the
scene and this is what it's got to be
motion capture allows you to have a
little more freedom because you don't
need there's no focus marks or it's like
Oh Cameron you know you can you can feel
free to move around a little bit have a
little more freedom and I think also
similarly in a booth you know as long as
you're in range of the mic you're
allowed to sort of like physically
express yourself anyway you need you to
reach that emotional point which is kind
of fun
and we did that a lot actually with meta
Madden because at a certain point in the
game we're essentially just playing
different levels of terror and fright
and fear is kind of a hard emotion to to
recreate such a physical emotion you
know it's like your hearts pounding
you're sweating it's like a very
visceral emotion so we would move around
a lot you know and it's kind of like a
cheating technique you know we could
like kind of run in place or move around
and get pumped up for for these scenes
we're like really scary things are
happening in the game so that was
actually kind of freeing and kind of fun
from a performance perspective when
you're acting out those scenes do you
kind of know as if isn't on that that
branching storyline is in the ultimate
end of that particular one or is it you
know you go by scene by scene so you're
feeling the terror as you your character
would be experiencing that's interesting
it seemed to me and it was a while ago
that we did it that we would try to
shoot out certain sections like the
locations that we were in so we would do
different variations in a location
essentially we're do scene by scene yeah
so so a working first scene that's got
that's got a load of branching in the
scene and it gets really complicated we
have this big float and a great
literally feels like a map in the studio
and it's like we the lines are so much
you get quite a similar line yeah well
with a subtle difference and we have to
kind of go back through all the branch
and go cane this is because
you said this to Julie or whatever and
now she's a bit annoyed with you so
that's why this line is here and then we
have to head back and do the next little
branch thing being annoying actors we
would ask that I was like wait why am I
asking this and Tommy we have to like
track back through the map and be like
remember Shawn we said this here I'm
like oh yeah but it does I really feel
like it does pay off like although all
the details although my new shop making
those decisions again for a player you
you that's what you're playing so that's
the story you're gonna see but when you
go back if you go back and play through
and make different decisions I think
it'll be exciting to feel that that
different narrative that different
moment it's like oh well when I saw this
last time it went this way and oh wow
it's very similar but there's these
slight differences and I think that's
kind of exciting and will be a good
reason people to go back and Riaan sis
it's really important for us that
players understand that every single
decision matters everything they do
no fake decisions everything matters
sometimes it's really subtle things like
how people respond to you sometimes it's
life and death before it'll open up a
whole new narrative branch so those
those subtle differences they really pay
off but players notice them all that's
because I was rude to that character why
I chose to say this it's really for me
Tom what makes it so super master based
in Guildford
that's right yeah yeah so what is it um
what's that supermassive DNA and what
and how do you get some sort of
quintessential British you because you
work with a lot of American actors a lot
of America American settings how do you
get how do you get what's in that DNA's
is I think a real passion for quality
that's that we want to make you know the
best games that the supermassive was not
a name that was chosen lightly you know
we want to be big and we know it's all
about quality so we've all we've always
had this ambition to make very vey
cinematic games and to take you know the
techniques some cinema and TV and learn
from and then we get really good at them
and be and be best in class
yeah Guildford it is a great place it's
got you know a huge development history
so many great Studios from Guildford
they call it kind of the Hollywood of
the games industry which is weird if you
know if you know Guildford and if you've
been to Hollywood but anyway
but so yeah it means that we have a load
of talented people you know that though
there's a bunch of talented people
working we get we can access that talent
and it's about just building a great
studio yeah well Tom Sean thank you so
much for joining us when can people at
home play Manorville done it is released
on August 30th and we cannot waive these
played not long to wait
thanks again thank you if you're
watching at home make sure to stay tuned
because we'll be right back with Dragon
Quest builders to
[Music]
[Applause]